في الجزائر وضع الصحفي احسان القاضي مدير
اذاعه ام قيد الحبسي الاحترازي بعد مثله
اليوم امام قاضي التحقيق ووجهت اليه تهم
تلقي تمويلا اجنبي وبسي اخبار مزيفه
حول هذا الموضوع نستقبل من الجزائر
العاصمه الصحفي خالد الدرارني وممثل
مراسلنا بلا حدود في شمال افريقيا اهلا بك
على
التهام تحديدا التي وجهت في حقي الصحفي
حسن القاضي
مساء الخير الى احد الان نحن لا نملك
التفاصيل حول التهم لان الاحسان القاضي
عرض امام القاضي تحقيق بغياب محاميه الذي
لم يكفيهم الوقت للوصول
للتحقيق مع القاضي ولكن الاخبار المتداوله
من طرف هيئه الدفاع ومن عائله حسن قاعده
تقول بان الاتهامات يمكن ان يكون لها
ارتباط بالماده 95 و96 من قانون العقوبات
فيما يخص التمويل اجنبي وتمويل الجمعيات
وبقانون المتعلق بالتبرعات وهذا يعني هناك
اراده همم
لان نعطي بعض المعطيات والدلائل ان ممكن
اذاعه ام وسائل الاعلام التي كان
القاضي همم لها هذه العلاقه وقد تم
اغلاقها للاشاره لكن كيف تقيم اولا همم
لماذا همم ما هي الحاجه الى وضعه قيد
الحبس همم
طرازي همم بدايه وكيف تقيمون وضع حريه همم
الصحافه في الجزائر خلال همم السنوات
الاخيره
هل كان من اللازم ان يوضع احسان القاضي في
الحبس الاحتياطي طبعا لا لانه صحفي قام
بعمله كصحفي همم كتب مقالات بصفه حره
ومستقله وهذا القرار قرار الحبس الاحتياطي
وضعنا كلنا تحت الصدمات طبعا الصحفيين
المنظمات الدوليه المدافعه عن حريه
الصحافه عن حريه التعبير نحن لا نفهم الى
حد الان لماذا الحبس الاحتياطي الصحفي قام
بعمله الان ننتظر قرار غرفه الاتهام لدى
محكمه الجزائر التي ستقوم باعطائه باصدار
امرها بعد اسبوعين حول قبول الاستئناف او
رفض هذا الحديث الاحتياطي
تحول او وضع حريه الاعلام في الجزائر
سنوات الاخيره
سنه القاضي ونحن طلبنا منذ الرابع
والعشرين من ديسمبر يعني تاريخ اعتقاله
هنا في الرسائل العاصمه طلبنا بالافراج
عنه بانهاء كل المضايقات ضده وبايعاده فتح
وسائل الاعلام اذاعه امم وماذهب طبعا
حاله الصحافه في الجزائر هي حاله مقلقه
شده اليوم بعد اغلاق
[موسيقى]
العديد من الصحفي تحت الرقابه القضائيه
همم منذ 20 نوفمبر لا يوجد صحفي في السجن
ولكن الان مع احسان القاضي يوجد صحفي واحد
جزائري في السجن هذه الحاله وهذه السياسه
المبرمجه
ينتقل بانها ليست في صالح الصحافه وليست
في صالح سوره الجزائر في العالم
خالد درارني الصحفي وممثل موران منظمه
مراسلين من بلا حدود في شمال افريقيا كنت
معنا من الجزائر العاصمه شكرا جزيلا لك